leute wenn wir auf insgesamt volk weiß
bereits ich bin seit ein paar tagen hier
auf madeira zusammen mit dave sebastian
ganz vielen anderen und ich dachte mir
wenn ich schon auch mal ihren unterricht
auf ein video und ich werde zusammen mit
den jungs eine app spielen jetzt photo
roll at das klingt irgendwie so ein
bisschen wie statement ist es nicht nur
das gestern abend einmal gezeigt
zusammen mega lustig die app ist einfach
bei jedem teilnehmer ein foto aus der
galerie und das wird an allen gezeigt
man muss raten von wem es ist also es
können ziemlich peinliche sachen dabei
sein bleibt auf jeden fall dran und dann
zu schauen was dabei rumkommt und ich
würde sagen wir setzen uns jetzt mit den
anderen drinnen zusammen und legen
einfach los so leute wie sie jetzt hier
ich starte ein spiel in der app create
game foto dpad und die leute alle sind
im spiel ist es immer der kleinste
nervenkitzel bei dieser app weil das
kann wirklich alles aus der fotogalerie
kommt es seit passwörter nacktfotos
fertigen haben sollte
das tut mir leid 32
aber noch keine peinlichen fotos dabei
ja okay okay wir könnten doch sie habe
keine ahnung wie bisher nichts
doch bald kommt schon achtmal die 8 x 1
1 gespielt hat und nicht hinpassen würde
nein das war lewis hamilton ein
lohan freundl euro
ich kannte das foto ap los manche sachen
müssen wir zensieren weil privat fürs
internet aber das war bisher noch
relativ moderat oder weil irgendwas
wofür ich geschenkt haben
leider bin ehrlich und die meisten
sachen für euch drei gar nicht kennen
die momentane kennt die du musst
verlegen
guido kuphal rieti herr komplette elite
sich gegen versprochen wir haben das ist
doch okay er wird für sein ok ich hab
keinen diese person ist also ich würde
sagen dass ein fotograf und sowas wie
schreibtische aussuchen für seinen dort
ja wer ist das der aussenseiter dann
doch nicht gezeigt werden
mein herz schlägt immer schneller
wahrscheinlich so ein scheiß foto von
mir selbst dachte wir selbst
regenschirme den können iphone reden
doch eher stabil und text auf jeden fall
da alter platten und weniger als ihr die
sache ist er bei marathon wieder ganz
gestern schon gespielt und man weiß nie
genau
nur wenn man max gesichts sei weiß man
nicht ob es wirklich auch maxis foto ist
weil es könnte gut sein dass ich dabei
bin habe ich gesagt ja
oh mein gott meine erste sebastian will
der klickt das jetzt kommen wir so
bekannt was muss ich sagen das ist es
keine ahnung ich weiß selber ich weiß
nicht wo das sollte wenn ich nur bei
einfach weg und schon kommst du warst
weg nach new york die spiel zu und wird
geredet für die nacht
das muss jetzt gemacht dass ein gerät
vor date die knapp guck mal zu mir ich
habe dreimal hintereinander gewonnen
na ja ein recht was er sagt wir sehen
einfach so gekommen ist gestern schon
mal ein spiel gestern mit den jungs von
gewitter im kopf die mussten heute schon
abweisend der hat sich gestern schon so
hinterwirth richtig krass immerhin
frauen drauf waren denn was im
maximalfall fotografiert ihre fenster im
wiso landschaften war damals immer jan
von gewittern bei auto überhaupt das
nicht geschafft so hunger ist einfach um
die von diesem kabel da somit aber so
habe sein vater kabelsalat es anders
lettern ok letzte runde letzte runde
leute ich hab richtig
nein ich bin so
und hat man es ist das letzte alte frau
kurz ob ich es gemacht habe und damit
wird der mensch denkt bei der wir selber
so verbessert dass potthast einfach mal
kapitän wieder würden nur am 11
diese gebaut dass ich für mich getan
habt ihr alle aufwendig zum mixen
dabei verschickte lag er damit dass
monica ist das passt ja heute nennen
dieses schöne ist taxe basteln das team
will das ist wieder aufgehoben und
wieder ja ja ja
100.000 jahrhundert
ich glaube ich hab alles bliebe wäre
gerne der marder so schlemmer ein no-go
ich hab ich aber immer genau wissen wir
das ist hier neben smart energy kauft so
leute das war's vom heutigen video ich
hoffe es hat euch spaß gemacht falls es
euch spaß macht dann schafft er in die
kapitale daneben noch ein zweiter teil
hauptgruppe der regel vorbeigucken dabei
helfe dabei kommt doch weil sebastian
vorbei wir sehen uns beim nächsten video
wieder das wäre es mit wolf